Move the orange dot
to negative 2 plus 2i.
So we have a
complex number here.
It has a real part, negative 2.
It has an imaginary
part, you have 2 times i.
And what you see
here is we're going
to plot it on this
two-dimensional grid,
but it's not our
traditional coordinate axes.
In our traditional
coordinate axis,
you're plotting a real x value
versus a real y-coordinate.
Here on the horizontal
axis, that's
going to be the real part
of our complex number.
And our vertical axis is going
to be the imaginary part.
So in this example,
this complex number,
our real part is the
negative 2 and then
our imaginary part
is a positive 2.
And so that right over
there in the complex plane
is the point negative 2 plus 2i.
Let's do a few more of these.
So 5 plus 2i.
Once again, real part is
5, imaginary part is 2,
and we're done.
Let's do two more of these.
1 plus 5i.
1-- that's the real part--
plus 5i right over that Im.
All right, let's do
one more of these.
4 minus 4i.
Real part is 4, imaginary
part is negative 4.
And we're done.